so tell me where I suck man tell me
where I can improve and how can get
better you know that consistency and
branding is really important our brains
love patterns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up believe nation it's seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine I'm on a mission to hit
ten million subscribers on my youtube
channel I need to get better I need to
push harder I need to break comfort
zones and so this week on my path to 10
million I bring on one of my friends and
one of the people that I look up to in
the YouTube world Jeremy vest as he
breaks down tears apart my channel and
gives me some advice and feedback on how
to get better
I hope you enjoy I am here with the
youtube master a longtime friend some
guy who always kicks my ass on YouTube
stuff mr. Jeremy vest from vid IQ how
you doing man
hey I'm doing great thanks for having me
on so my goal is to get the 10 million
subscribers I'm sitting here at 1.7 I
need help to get there and I give you
access to my channel and you've been
diving deep and getting into it so so
tell me where I suck man tell me where I
can improve and how I can get better
yeah let's dive right in I'm gonna share
my screen here first thing and you know
you definitely have always had
phenomenal thumbnails and I know a lot
of people have to make your thumbnails
get better the truth is your thumbnails
are amazing like you know you've done a
lot of multivariate testing and you know
exactly where you stand with your
thumbnails the two things I think that
you still struggle with on your
thumbnails honestly yeah is consistency
even though when you do like the 10
rules and get attention and you know
they're very similar but I feel like for
example some of these not actually some
of them are private so I'm
looking at stuff you don't see but I
feel like that you could have a little
more consistency but the biggest and I
think you're missing is a reason to
click so like intrigue like interesting
just weird stuff in the background and
Dan Locke is kicking butt obviously and
he's doing a good job and I really like
how I'm doing these just textures and
things in the background just make it
more visually interesting so my
challenge to you is to just find more
interesting things to put in the
background I think your text is is
phenomenal
I have too much it's not too little it's
right there in the right space so the
two things as I just try to get more
consistent even though you're very
consistent not even get more consistent
and then instead of the black background
I would have more just texture of just
cool weird stuff happening that really
paints the visual picture of the visual
storytelling that you're trying to tell
no I was thinking so if we take one of
these that we're looking at and yeah I
think a good chunk is our private so
we're not getting that full picture but
like let's take mark humans best advice
there I think we took this from you to
where you said hey we want a big picture
zoom in on their face so I know who it
is even though I'm Athena von Mobile so
I've got mark we're filling the rest of
the screen with him saying or with with
the title you know he was the best
advice that the text what should we do
to make that thumbnail better in the
background what do you think in this
particular case I would study the video
and I'd really understand like what
advice you're talking about and I would
pull a visual from that advice or I
would find some interesting picture of
Mark Cuban so it's either and I probably
multivariate very test both of these but
it would either be like a Mark Cuban
type of visual you know like something
he's known for like the Dallas Mavericks
or you know something like that
or actually create like a visual
storytelling visual elements from his
advice
either way the idea is to draw in the
eye
make it more clickable so that's more
interesting and when you look at some of
these Dan Locke videos here's like a
fence back here and you just have weird
pictures and just colors it almost
doesn't matter what it is it's
interesting you don't know what I mean
it just draws you in more it's more in a
way it's almost more clickable I do
think the size of your heads and you
know the size of your text and all that
stuff is literally mere perfect as far
as saying I've done and you know the
size eyes are the window to the soul and
all that stuff that we've done before I
really think that you've really really
you know hit the nail on the head with
most of the stuff I think it's just a
texture thing it's it's getting that
intriguing and you know one one thing I
want to make sure your audience is
really we're aware of is how important
thumbnails are and even how important
are they to you right after the video
it's the thing like right after the the
quality of the video making sure you
have a good video because a great
thumbnail won't save a crappy video
because people will tune out but if
you've got a good video then thumbnail
is this thing that we spend the most
time on we agonize over the most I'm
super proud that a lot of people know
what a never chemical thumbnail is I
think most of your view is least on my
channel come from suggested and so a lot
of times people will watch our video and
then you see my videos down the side you
know which ones are mine where people
who don't have consistent thumbnails
they don't you don't know you don't know
that that's your video
you're losing views on your channel
because even though your video is coming
up and suggested people don't know that
that's your video and the thumbnail is
the first way to do it so we spend a lot
of time on it but but I know I need to
get better and that's the thing a lot of
people don't realize is branding like
making sure you know if you have a store
or a type of car anything in marketing
and branding you know that consistency
and branding is really important for
some reason most brands and most
youtubers don't actually take this into
consideration for their thumbnails and
every single thumbnail is different from
each other and that really creates a lot
of confusion and and what happens with
your thumbnails for example
is people see like let's say on the
right hand side is where most organic
traffic comes from by the way for most
channels if people see your thumbnail
like number seven one three and nine
position our brains love pattern so it's
like the matrix happening and your brand
brand brand brand is gonna pop out like
the matrix and people are gonna have
more they're gonna just be more likely
to see and click on your thumbnails
because it creates this pattern in our
brain so branding is so unbelievably
important and and also the three E's
eyes excitement and emotion you do a
great job with those so if we look at
this Cuban one am i keeping that picture
and that text and just throwing
something around it or am i swapping the
picture out for something else
what do you think depending on how many
pictures you had what would probably be
the best-case scenario is if you had him
in like a city scene or doing something
crazy with his hands or you know like
screaming or doing like the youtuber
face with action emotion excitement so
maybe like he's downtown Dallas or he's
in the you know the Mavs arena like way
more emotional so if you had more images
I would say a lot same face size a lot
more emotion and then just stuff
happening in the background or we could
add things to this background with this
image the thing I don't like about this
image is he's smiling and I personally
when I think of Mark Cuban I think of
him a lot more intense yes he smiles you
know I think of him a lot intense than
that so the emotional engagement side of
it I I think in G people are smiling and
your thumbnails and that's great but I
guarantee you if you got just way more
emotional shots in general it's going to
create more intrigue got it because
people smiling that's not really a
reason for me to click what if Oprah
Winfrey look like she's about to punch
somebody you know
as long as a dog can't be a cat you
can't make you know it's we're not
making clickbait we're making clickbait
is when you don't deliver but just a
great title and a great thumbnail is you
actually deliver that information so
more emotionally engaged intense reasons
to click so just think to yourself you
know is Mark smiling gonna make me click
maybe not but if he's like upset or like
intense maybe I'm like oh you know I've
subconsciously there's like a three
percent more likely encode of me
clicking if it's an intense face right
okay so so that style is pretty standard
for most of my videos most of my series
probably 80% of my videos will have that
style of the face on one side pretty
zoomed in text on the left if you look
at the next line there's two videos
there that are a different style
it says prove them wrong and then
ultimate comeback stories where we're
mashing multiple people together instead
of just one character yeah how are those
doing by the way the belief life one the
second one the ultimate comeback stories
one we've had some big success with some
of those but it's now four people or
five people or ten people instead of
just one big person but maybe they could
be doing better so I ran the study in
two to three phases in general sometimes
do better than one it depends on the
scene you know it depends on a lot of
things personally my guest would be the
prove them wrong three bigger faces
where I could see the whites of their
eyes and their expressions and emotions
will do a better click-through rate
typically than the ultimate comeback
stories with four people
I think four people is too many to show
expressions of emotions and eyes
excitement and things like that
so two to three I think would be
ultimate when you do that I think four
plus is going to just it's gonna be hard
for people to even know what that little
dot is you
well on the right hand side it's gonna
be too small for people to relate to
that person right okay and if you look
the next line down there's two people
there's one versus another yeah we've
made it even bigger so we've been player
versus Gabe yeah that's that's great
yeah that that looks really really good
and then I would just make sure I
understood what that you know the
impressions two views and click-through
rates were on those I really liked
Bryant's ten rules because he's intense
and he has this finger up number one
that that's a phenomenal thumbnail to me
if he was in a basketball court or had
some like really cool background you
know some reason to click back there or
visually showed like one of the rules
maybe the one of the rules is like never
give up and he's like just sweating or
you know what I'm saying like just yeah
more emotionally intense which
subconsciously will give someone a
reason to click got it okay good
takeaways all right the next piece of
advice I I know I've told you before and
I'm gonna just nail you on again oh and
this is in the pain yeah is writing
trends so you do a phenomenal job of
cranking out content you are a Content
machine yer your guy you you guys are
like literally probably the best company
I know of cranking out content you guys
are just a frickin machine but what I
think to get to that ten million you
know like you know eight thousand more
than where you are now is I really think
you guys are gonna have to ride some of
these trends I'm gonna show you a few
examples of what we've done here if it
IQ in the last few months and mind you
we have two hundred and fifty thousand
two hundred sixty thousand subscribers
but I want to some of the trends we were
writing and they make sense for us these
trends may not make sense for you but
with two hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers we just got in in the last
month or so we've got our first 1
million viewed video with mr. beast and
I don't know if you've heard
about this but basically PewDiePie
t-series are fighting to be the biggest
subscribe channels in the world vid IQ
we help people get more views and
subscribers so I made a lot of sense for
us to talk about this and then this
other third youtuber came in mr. beast
and he's disrupting and getting
PewDiePie a lot more views and a lot
more subscribers so we did this video on
this and boom we got a million views now
one of the biggest reasons we were able
to get a million views on this is we're
at the exact right place at the right
time and what I mean by that is we saw
things happening and we bounced on it
the second was happening another example
is YouTube rewind within 24 hours of
YouTube rewind coming out and very
definitely people started realizing that
it was not going in a good direction we
bounced on it we made a video and we had
250,000 views organic views on a you
know on a video where we only have
250,000 subscribers so that's a pretty
substantial size for the size of the
channel we have and we also did it in
the perspective of YouTube analytics and
you know how we teach people how to do
things I think a lot of times when
people bounce on trends they don't stay
true to themselves and they don't
provide the unique value that they give
to their audience so the trick is how
does the Evan Carmichael brand find
trends relate that to what you bring to
the world make a spin on this unique
topic in your perspective so we're able
to do it pretty well so far we've been
just doing this for you know four or
five months we have several videos you
know two three four or five 600,000
views a million views and it has really
helped the growth of our overall channel
you know our typical video gets five six
seven thousand views 14,000 views and
you know
we're doing these spikes of quarter
million a half a million the million
views and that's really changed the
dynamic and growth of our channel
fundamentally so I think for you to get
to that next level that you know 10
million 20 million 50 billion I think
you're gonna have to really bounce on
those trends what would be a trend
that's happening now and I mean we're
filming this before it goes live I guess
but what's something happening now that
you could see me bouncing off of well
well let's let's do it real time so I'm
gonna click on most-viewed I'm not
promoting vid IQ by the way but we do
have a cool tool that kind of shows
what's trending now we have this concept
called vph that's views per hour or
velocity so let's type in a trend like
success I'm gonna type in the search
term success and now I'm actually this
week I'm actually gonna see the highest
views per hour trending dos for the word
success so one of the ideas you can do
is you can use a tool like this or this
tool and you can understand what is
trending in the world obviously you can
look at Twitter you can look at Facebook
you can look at news but essentially
when things are happening real time like
wreck threats all the crazy stuff
happening with Brett's at this this week
you know would be a good example that's
its leadership you do a lot of
leadership stuff and you know leadership
is a huge part of what's happening with
brexit people don't trust in her anymore
and you know everything's falling apart
kind of for them right now and it's in
turmoil another example would be
something to do with Donald Trump but
not in a negative way not to bring the
world down but to bring the world up you
know how leaders lead or you know things
like that and use news events for good
not bad because I know you're all about
you know building people up and and May
believe in making this world a better
place
so I think you could use these as a
positive not as a negative a lot of
people use news events and trumpet
crazies happening in the world for
negative reasons you know they're just
piling and on that trend but if you
could stay true to your brand and you
can these events to create phenomenal
content then I I think it just makes a
lot of sense it's about identifying the
trends that are happening this moment
what I typically do is I start with the
tool like this first thing I do is I
actually I don't type in any search
terms I just see okay in the past 48
hours what's the highest trending videos
right now and most bit mr. beast of
course
music there's always going to be toys
and games and how-to stuff and for
tonight you have the typical stuff but
then you know you can start adding in
words and figuring it out this would be
like an exercise I would literally do
like maybe have a team member do 10 15
20 minutes a day from here I would go to
Twitter and and I would well that shows
what's most trending on Twitter and then
I would I would hit like the major news
another thing we've done on vid IQ as we
do trends specifically for YouTube so
for example YouTube hashtags when a new
feature comes out for YouTube if you
notice we ranked number one and two in
the world for the word YouTube hashtags
or YouTube hashtag and and the reason
for that honestly is we're right when it
was coming out we stayed up late that
night and we made that content and what
happens is the lobby so we were the
answer to the question youtube hashtags
and we were very in the world to answer
that question people started typing in
hey what are these new YouTube hashtags
and we
the number one result and because we
were there first you can see this video
has a hundred and thirty-five thousand
organic views on a video we typically
would get you know five thousand views
for right so being there first and
hedging your bets and making sure you're
trying to be there before other people
so for example on leadership funds a son
you know Dan Locke and all these big
famous people that you you talk about
and you share videos with finding what's
about to break in and being there first
is can be a huge reward even on my
little my little bitty channel my own
personal channel I have 4,000
subscribers on my personal channel to
YouTube hashtags I got 25,000 views
24,000 views on a channel with 4,000
subscribers so you don't have to be huge
to make this this strategy work but
being right there at the moment that
that things are happening I think could
be Games Inc for Evan Carmichael let me
ask you a question if you go back to the
yeah I go back to the so this is the V
IQ tool here if you scroll down I saw a
video that peak might there that mental
health break so there the try guys take
a mental health vacation so lice I saw
that one this morning on my own feed and
it's popping up here on your video cue
tool you know I could make a video or
how to avoid burnout unlike the try guys
or how do like something around burnout
or taking breaks or having to deal with
the stress of running the business and
tie these guys in somehow like if I use
them on the thumbnail tell their story
cook yeah
yeah and in comment and then give advice
on how to avoid mental burnout yeah
another thing you could do is mental
health vacation mental health burnout
you can kind of see what tags see it's
not about hijacking what they've done
but it's about building on their success
you know I'm speaking of econ one in
next next month and there's a whole
panel of people about YouTube and int'l
health it is a huge kind of almost
crisis at this point where people are
getting burnt out and
that's a big inning talk right now for
with YouTube creator so I would take
this to that next level where I'll also
do my keyword research around you know
burnout and YouTube burnout and you know
all of these these terms and really
understand some what searching for and
match that intensity of what's trending
does that make sense so you not only
would I make a video at the moment in
time that opening but I would also make
sure I answer the question people are
asking right I could just make a video
on mental health & burna which I
probably done already before but I want
to tie it to you these guys taking a
break and how how to avoid it right so I
want to tie these guys into the story
not just not just do a general thing on
mental health right right it doesn't
have to be a person place or thing
necessary they can be whatever the trend
is so I know that also just enjoy
youtubers but a specific youtuber
burning out is your your probably going
to have a there's going to be a more of
a reason to click so if I said their
green house or that house that's wide
over there versus the white house you
know the more specific you get the
bigger reason I have to click on a video
so if I started with something like the
try guys are a super successful YouTube
channel with five million subscribers
they've been making videos every week
for the past you know three years and
whatever will get the data but recent
they had to take a break because they
were having a mental burnout and then
show some clip that where they talked
about it burnout is common and here are
like five ways to go and overcome it and
then I share some advice on how to how
to break through absolutely and then I
would I would also kind of study what
they're ranking for and and you know
really understand the keyword universe
of round why this video success not just
the fact that they have five million
subscribers and that's probably why they
got two million views is probably beyond
that right there's watch this times
probably be they ranked number one in
the world for the word
hey so I would definitely yeah I would
use the word mental health I would do
something like five takeaways from the
trike from you know about mental health
with it with the Troy guys right so
you're doing almost doing this knots to
that video and you're talking about how
you know practical ways to not get burnt
out or or you know avoid mental health
problems and then how long do I have
this is trendy number one right now on
YouTube okay what's my window to release
this video it's a good question because
sometimes what happens is I will say in
general you want to be at the beginning
of that bell curve right so if stuffs
taking off less than 24 hours however
there are sometimes there's been tons
and tons of crazy weird trends you know
on YouTube over the last decade right
and sometimes like the ice bucket
challenge and you know some of these
other trends that have happened
sometimes a year later or six months
later becomes the biggest video and it's
not beginning so there's always there's
always ways to break out of this and
they're you know there's there's
exceptions to the rules but in general
you know my little channel with 4,000
subscribers got 25,000 views on the pill
with about YouTube hashtags because I
was at the beginning of that bell curve
of the people starting to ask those
questions so be it beginning as much as
you can be I need to ramp up my speed
we're not that fast yet we gotta get
there the idea though is what if you
just did it once a month or once um you
know like just start start disrupt your
flow you know for a few tests and then
see what happens another thing I can say
about shareable viral videos as you know
is it's hit or miss I mean in we
couldn't absolutely you know uploaded
the wrong timer that mr. beefs video
could have had a thousand views not a
million views like sometimes it's
literally just hit or remove yeah
we did a silly egg video the other day
that got like 5,000 views and mr. beast
has millions of views so sometimes it's
hit or miss but it is to do is I like to
do shareable videos 20% of the time and
just laying bricks content just you know
building the foundation of your
subscriber base in your views 80% of the
time but my recommendation to your team
and you is even if you have to cut back
your existing content schedule 20% of
the time go for shareable content ok the
next thing I want to show is doubling
down on the success you have so we have
this and you're very familiar with the
channel audit tool but we basically and
and your number one goal Evon right now
is to get to 10 million subscribers
right so we actually show how how you're
getting the most subscribers right now
your think & Grow Rich summary book
stuff is actually giving you the most
subscribers per 1000 views so what I
would actually do is I would go look and
see like your top 20 videos of just
killing subscribers in the last 30 days
and I'm gonna I'm gonna say okay these
are the videos that are that are giving
you the most subscribers let's go do
more of that just doubling down on the
things getting you the most subscribers
what's interesting here is I guess it's
because it's per 1000 views because none
of these videos are actually any of my
top videos but I guess it's because it's
on it's per one kind of 1000 views right
yeah but if it's not a popular video
like if that if one of those videos only
got me 5000 views or something okay
maybe I got and yeah okay we do that for
a reason if you have a video of 5
million views and you know it got you a
hundred thousand subscribers maybe this
isn't the best way for you to look at it
but you can also look at it at 90 days
and you can look at it in various ways
to make
different but fun them I do think this
is a good way to to look at so every
video you do whether it's a you know a
big video or a small video I think this
is a really cool way to just kind of say
okay I'm gonna Sime gonna focus on the
videos that are getting me the most
subscribers down here you can actually
see videos that are not doing as well
you're maybe possibly even losing
subscribers so it just helps your focus
on what is working the best for your
goal of 10 million subs so yeah that
would be and you know this is a
simplistic tool but it's also really
powerful because it shows you exactly
what's working based on engagement and
views and subscriber gain and watch time
and retention but it offers you what you
know has the the least amount of views
and watch time and subscriber gains
right so I think it's a pretty neat way
to look at things and I see what you're
saying maybe we should add an option to
say like all-time as well that way you
can see like you know overall how many
subscribers that you've gained on a
video that's a really good point that's
my three tips for you and hopefully that
helps yeah I mean I love this audit tool
I look at this at least once a week when
I log into my YouTube back-end I've seen
subscribers gain part of it I love it's
interesting that the book review like 1
& 2 are both book reviews those are not
big videos but maybe if we did book
reviews but in a bigger way or did a
better job on it and the video actually
did pop chances I would do better and
that's why I like to look at it this way
it's all like you've built your channel
doing like almost 3 videos a day right
so you've built your channel on I call
that laying the foundation or you know
brick by brick you you have some big
videos that got 5 million views and you
know you have some big big huge viral
successes but fundamentally you
have built this thing brick by brick one
at a time and looking at it like this
without you know all time but looking at
it just the videos that are driving the
most subscribers I would even challenge
you to change your current content
schedule to match what's driving the
most subs so even if let's say these
book review videos are only getting
10,000 or 50,000 views each if
fundamentally we find that they're
driving more subscribers then it helps
you reach your goal faster got it
interesting okay cool man I'm gonna dive
deeper dude appreciate the time when the
love and the energy if people want to
find more about you I know you've got
your own channel vid IQ like where do
you want them to go what's the next step
yeah they can check out video comm we
have a lot of free tools it's pretty
cool and you can find me at youtube.com
slash Jeremy vest and you've got this
great video where you dissect a hundred
different thumbnails how many did you do
in that video 52 I remember it was a
full hot yet for anybody who wants to do
thumbnails it's a great video where
every basically four or five seconds he
shows a new thumbnail and then I think
it's that same scale you did a motion
your ease right yeah I caching reasons
that reason to click I forget what they
were but the super cool since I guess
it's a really quick education going
through a whole bunch of different
thumbnails so I would start on the video
like that we'll link that up in the
description too for everybody who wants
to go check those out appreciate you man
thank you follow someone well thanks for
having me on if you like this one and
you want to see Hank Norman tear into me
and make me a better coach check the
link right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there